[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oui
mais
[Musique]
les
à mon avis
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à voir
[Musique]
vous
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oui
et bien bonjour bienvenue
il est venu pour ce stream du mercredi
là
on est ensemble pour jouer la reine
blitz hebdomadaire leach s
adoncques
5 0 donc il va durer trois heures
salut à tous donc on va essayer de tenir
les trois heures
pour essayer de faire un résultat c'est
de jouer aux échecs cet après midi alors
vous pouvez rejoindre le tournoi sur
leach s
donc c'est le tournant standard rich ès
arts et de beats hebdomadaire
donc pour le rejoindre doute à peser
dans jouer tournoi
voilà bien aidé sur cette page est elle
est là ici à rennes ii bis hebdomadaire
en orange
voilà ça fait partie des gros tournois
l'ensemble thiès il ya plusieurs types
de gros tournois redon qui sont marqués
plus ou moins dans le calendrier alors
par contre ce que je m'explique pas
c'est qu'ils ont tous lu à 17 heures
heure française je sais pas pourquoi
qu'est ce qui se passe pour ceux qui
quoi ya pas de tournoi à d'autres heures
avec ses mondiale
je me l'expliqué pas
mais bon c'est comme ça
quand orange c'est les hebdomadaires
le jaune c'est les tourner en élite
c'est ça titled way too tight aux élites
je crois c'est plus de mille deux mille
deux cents lots titled il faut deux
titrés
donc ça va de leech s-master en fait il
ya une titre leach s-master bon il ya
des titres de maîtres internationaux
grands maîtres internationaux classique
en fait un bond de 3 réservé pour ces
titres qui sont les titres fidéen
voilà
qu est ce qu il yad autres ah oui alors
en rouge c'est le cd trouva mensuel par
exemple la reine blitz mensuelle aura
lieu le 29 avril
donc c'est la semaine prochaine par
exemple si je vais voir celle là
ça dure quatre heures là c'est un peu
plus long
parce qu'il est dommage par contre s'il
n'y a pas deux il n'y a pas de groupe à
gagner bons
parce qu'après il ya les gros tournois
alors les arènes il ya une coupe a gagné
mais que pour le vainqueur donc bon
c'est quand même assez limité et à prier
une coupe a gagné aussi pour les taux -
bleu où cela la summer matar marathon là
le 1er août où la première août
voilà il ya une coupe voilà il ya ce
très beau s'être belle très belle coupe
à gagner qui arrive sur votre profil si
mal à gagner alors par contre il suffit
d'être enfin vite pour lui de gagner me
feriez dans les 100 premiers voilà pour
ça il n'y a pas d'autres types de
trophées sur leach s
comment ça se présente c'est dans votre
profil
voilà ça apparaît là en fait dans
l'android aucune couple âgé rien du tout
et le classement ici par déjà commencé a
fait quelques petits rats parties
rapides là cet après midi j'ai joué
quelques parties rapides dans le tournoi
échec et stratégie
de mon ami philippe dans mouche
qu'a fait un petit tournoi par six pme
peu j'ai fait quoi je fais 5 400 partis
je sais plus donc ça a activé un petit
peu mon classement rapide je pars de
tout en bas je veux démarrer à 1500 sans
doute
un peu plus
là c'est marqué l'échec et stratégies
arena
on se donne tournoi rapide quelques
partis en début d'après midi
donc il ya le marathon en le marathon
c'est dur par contre ça dure
24 heures d'affilée web
je ferais pas ça c'est du bullet en plus
un
le pas de bullet
voilà ça va démarrer dans cinq minutes
alors salut à antoine bauza qui nous a
rejoints dans le tchat
salut antoine bonheur
et que dans le profilage apparaît ici
comme on est en train de stream et si je
clique dessus
voilà il a repris le fil le flux twitch
accord
qui
alors à noter week aujourd'hui je
récupère
j'envoie le stream sur
sur le mini aux échecs voilà je vais
décide d'en faire deux cette semaine on
faire
[Musique]
de temps en temps quand même puisque
c'est quand même la chaîne historique à
bonal tv où il ya tout le catalogue
historique
avec nos amis de diminuer
en attendant de faire quelques stream on
a fait quelques zones déjà de direct
aussi on avait fait du championnat de
france rapide féminin
de d'angoulême je crois ou de villandry
je sais plus
sur une échelle
mais fait aussi une
festival international de perpignan
que stream là votre le peut-être le
quatrième je sais plus
alors charles ives halton salut je suis
fan depuis longtemps j'espère tu
affrontes hebei a pas de problème
charlie si tu suis diagonale tv alors à
noter que dans la description de la
vidéo vous avez aussi toutes les chaînes
d bonal tv sur twitch pour ceux qui ont
l'habitude de twitch je diffuse en
partie sur twitter quand je peux donc la
part entre ce stream normalement il doit
être sur ce trait il est sûr switch
aussi et puis aussi la chaîne du tout
les gones halte et veolia que les vidéos
diagonale tv est sur une ligne au
tchèque qui a des vidéos qui sont pas de
donald tv en plus
un mélange
alors en tout
monsieur inscrits auront récemment sur
l'it chaise je peux pas participer au
tournoi il faut avoir fait minimum fait
partie oui c'est vrai antoine c'est vrai
c'est vrai mais bon tu peux suivre le
direct et tu peux apprendre et puis la
prochaine fois ce sera plus fort allez
alors notez qu'il y aura sans doute un
tournoi diagonale tv donc aller vous
inscrire dans l'équipe diagonale tv sur
les chefs vous allez dans communauté
équipe communauté équipe là vous faites
toutes les équipes vous tapez diagonale
avec le tv vous trouvez l'équipe
diagonale tv on regarde et je vais vous
le faire ici
voilà donc je vais dans ici mes équipes
toutes les équipes là en haut à droite
vous taper tout simplement ici pour
taper diagonale tv si vous n'êtes pas
encore dedans
voilà vous avez l'équipe diagonale tv
ici il ya déjà 2 158 membres inscrits je
suis assez impressionné
je l'écris il ya pas longtemps ça fait
j'ai bu deux ou trois semaines trois
semaines peut-être
on va le voir une façon il n'y a pas de
date non
moi voilà il ya ses marques et là ya un
mois encore défaut continuelle - c'est
pas une date exacte
le 16 mars un peu plus d'amour l'accord
ans ça fait un peu plus d'un mois ça
fait un mois une semaine voilà cinq
semaines quoi
à noter exactement et j'avais jamais
l'ancien premier tournoi à huit joueurs
maintenant les derniers tournois on
commence a culminé à 70,80 déjà inscrit
ça monte
et puis à 258 membres dans l'équipe
plaisir d'avoir pauline autres chaises
qui avait joué aussi avec nous et qui
fait des stream en même temps de temps
en temps bons éléments ne présente en ce
moment parce que bon le
à suivre sans doute la scolarité il a un
peu un peu moins présente
mais bon il ya du monde dans le dans
l'équipe donc si vous êtes dans l'équipe
et b brosseau vont automatiquement un
message quand je crée un tournoi
j'envoie un message au bar en moi
j'essaie de pas envoyé trop jeunes un
moyen pour dire voilà il ya un tournoi
et puis s'agit pas de vous polluez de
messages mais
ça vous permet d'être prévenu et puis
quand on entend vous allez voir l'équipe
qu'on fait partie d'une équipe et les
tournois qui sont réservées à l'équipe
ils sont marqués là
voilà donc vous pouvez revoir les
anciens et puis vous brancher sur les
nouveaux alors attention ça va démarrer
dans quinze secondes
cette arène beats hebdomadaire ya déjà 5
105 joueurs et on est 14e et l'eau pour
l'instant c'est pas mal
15e et l'eau
si on pouvait terminer 15e à la fin je
serais très content
allez c'est parti on joue face à
augustin ares aller augusta la res pour
l'instant score vierge ses marques et en
bas allez on en boit avec 4 alors
attention c'est du 5 0 c'est pas ma
cadence préféré il faut que je fasse
attention à ça
alors c'est 6
les quatre
food et 3 c3
scène carrément
on va prendre on a joué deux ans lula
c'est un pion isolés ici
le livre iii
pas les petits rock
je crois
moi
donc
don d un an mais la pression tout de
suite sur le pion de 5
mais si c'est normal foot 3
au troc a laissé 4
on va jouer toute l'année des deux avec
l'idée de jouer calais b trois cas les
d4 l'idée c'est de il faut bloquer les
pions isolé
donc on va le bloquer en d4
que les baies 3 une très belle case ici
après je fais attention sur des coups
comme kbc 4 faut jamais prendre ici
parce qu'en cas de prise du fou on
reprendre la tour et après on se prend
un échec la violent et ensuite tourner
vite prendre et ça s'appelle un attaque
à la découverte
donc il faut faire attention à ça en
tout cas les d4 qui est plus logique
et on va pouvoir chasser ce cavalier
sans doute par b3
tout simplement
sans faire de vagues
alors où là il ya plein de plein de
messages dans le chat je vais je me
concentre sur la partie pour l'instant
un piège j'ai envie de faire bouger 5
allez je tente le piège pouvait 5
sont trop bien le piège là
sur m6 évidemment on prend
[Musique]
si m6 on prend le cavalier le fou et
ensuite il ya un méchant coup g4 qui
cloue là avec cluj sur échec
[Musique]
lorsqu'on joue b3
on veut tout b3
donc ça va pas marcher notre pillage est
un petit piège bronchera pas marché
alors attention ici puisqu'on peut jouer
tout b5 mais on va pas le faire tout de
suite on peut aussi faire faut être
quatre cavaliers f3 cavale et prend feu
prend 1,4 mb 51.94 c'est possible
il tombe pas dans les pièges
il tombe pas dans le piège l'animal
allez on prend
il tombe pas dans le piège l'animal on
revient arrive 3 allez on continue à
mettre la pression sur ce pion des 5
alors on peut faire cavalier 2
faire cavaler ces deux aussi on peut
faire tourner de tout simplement
tu as l'air très bien tour d2 avec
l'idée simplement de doubler les tours
on a une position supérieure ici c'est
certain maintenant c'est à la
transformer ce qui n'est pas facile et
surtout la transformer sans perdre
autant et ça ça c'est le problème en
blitz aperto temps c'est toujours un peu
délicat
alors ici on peut jouer quatre peut-être
allez on va jouer avec quelque 4 pour
voir que font les noirs ici sur f4
pas facile
ce qu'on menace aussi f5
alors on peut jouer cinq cavale et
prendre des deux car il prend des quatre
tours prend va pas donc on va prendre
six
simplement
et simplement fou g4 clouage du pion aux
méchant clouage
allez oust c4
c'est bien vu c'est bien vu il s'en sort
le bourg
s'en sort le bourg
allez on va prendre
il joue très bien
joue très bien l'animal
voilà maintenant on va on envie de
revenir en f3 sans doute aller on menace
toujours de prendre ce fameux pions des
5 et noir souffre au mur noir plie mais
ne rompt pas allégé 3 on défend mon
opinion
drive 2 ans et d'améliorer la position
de nos pièces
ou 1
c'est pas facile hein
si l'un est très 5
le théâtre on essaie de pousser avec h3
allez on va tenter comme ça pour essayer
d'avancer côté côté le roi
c'est pas simple
allégez 4 on va prendre
on peut encore améliorer nos positions
ici
[Musique]
cheikh voir ce que font les ce que font
les noirs ici
allez on va descendre
mais c'est pas facile hein
tak tak peut-être peut-être fou 4
pagaille
ce continue échec
échec
émeutes
[Musique]
joli maths en plein centre de
l'échiquier il s'est mis juste à
l'endroit où il fait mater parce que
toutes les pièces blanches contrôle tout
en fait il pouvait encore revenir en d2
je pense
la position reste est resté sans doute
à la fois compliqué n'est pas clair
peut-être c'est lui qui est mieux que
son actif mais il se fait mater au
centre bon c'est un bon début on prend
on prend le match
merci alors
salut à sofiane a dit salut à charles
ives halton je suis président d'un club
en bourgogne j'ai pu rencontrer loi
saluée super salut chez charly et oui et
loi bien sûr et loi
loi qui se présentent à la fédération
française d'échecs cette année en tant
que candidat à la présidence voyez ça
vienne à tous dès bonal tv
ville diagonale tv
alors sofiane leach est un endroit pour
jouer aux échecs en ligne oui c'est
alors lithié c'est entièrement gratuit
pas de publicité et c'est entièrement
libre alors si vous vous demandez
comment il fait eh bien il fonctionne
uniquement sur les dons
ah les qualifs 3l droit donc de faire
des dons sur lynch est ce qu'elle est
c'est 6 elle est fou c'est 4 leurs a
priori 1129 lots c'est un stand joueurs
a priori
trop fort
ouais effectivement il à la chine pièce
il abandonne bon ok bon ça me prenait
facilement facilement gagner on le prend
on prendre tous les tous les
prendre tous les points pas de raison
sofiane cool je m'inscris aussi alors le
niveau est haut je suis comme un
débutant
alors pour ce tournoi là oui le tournoi
et eau le niveau est haut mais quand
vous voyez à beaucoup de joueurs 1194
donc si on va en fin de classement on
trouve des débutants en 1200 1041 voilà
il ya des débutants aussi à tous les
niveaux un simplement attendez-vous à
perdre plus de parties que vous avez
gagné mais c'est pas grave
chaque fois prendre un perdant peu aussi
moi j'en perds aussi un tout bon d'en
perdre et on va jouer des 5
prise câble et m6
j'ai un peu la dent prendre je fais 4e 6
mans
et donc là sans doute rouge et 4
quel c6
[Musique]
si seulement
2 4 kg va bouger pas où l'aca maintenant
il va le perdre l'ouïe sol et des roches
de sa dalle est ici
faut prendre à me prendre cavalier a ici
est obligé d'en venir en d1 on salaire
bien achevée le 4
sharifi que sheva gaza leurs bons et on
prend
autre
des six
[Musique]
sauf
500 lève la case ici pour le cavalier
là j'ai ma petite idée
alors on prend
on prend direct
kim a attaqué la dame là on a créé une
petite batterie aux menaces d'un promat
regard des cas pas le coup comme
l'egypte 4 alors que sinon il y avait le
cou qui régit catherine la petite idée
voilà je me lasse mattia pas câblée g4
il peut jouer j'ai trois mais dans ce
cas là il ya peut-être h4 ou là et donc
là il n'a pas vu et où il a oublié
l'échec est là c'est un peu fini on
attaque aux 4 mais on peut encore faire
échec
et quand le roi bien eux deux ils
bloquent la taxe sur le pion aux deux
donc je peux prendre g2 tranquillement
et le roi est toujours en grande
difficulté ici
position gagnant titien
or
embarquer tout simplement
il peut prendre ici mais alors voilà il
ne fait pas il a raison
on va faire échec
échec
je sers attention ici à pas
thelma tu reprends pas oublier nos
pièces ne fait pas de raison qu'ils
restent concentrés ici on a une position
archives écrasante
là donc là il lâche la tour avec échec
ou prendre une pression parce que la
dame peut pas s'échapper
allez donne la dame
le spectacle là je donne la dame et
après tour des huit mais il peut pas
empêcher échec suivi de tours d2 qui
récupère la dame minimum et c'est même
peut-être mat
alors on va essayer même de le mettre
match je pense
je fais ça
il prend 1,4 échec une montée échec
imagineront descendre
wayne on va faire échec tout simplement
on va tout est tranquille
cloud l'adami cloud et c'est à dire que
la dame peut pas prendre 4 parce que
l'échec derrière l' échec et ensuite au
pouce le pion pour les frères d'âme ils
abandonnent et on marque notre troisième
point donc ça c'est bien parce qu'on a
marqué les quatre points puisque son lit
chess donc quand vous marquez la
première fois vous marquez deux points
une deuxième fois d'affilée deux points
encore et si vous marquez trois fois
d'affilée vous marquez quatre là
maintenant si je marque je marque 4 4 4
tout le temps allez c'est parti on peut
aussi faire le père c'est qu'ici mais je
le fais pas c'est pas mon truc le
berserk le berserk sais que je peux
marquer un point de plus mais je risque
de tout perdre
allez on va refaire
la même variante là ça nous a réussi
avec clive 3 voilà qu'à lille 3 c'est
bien
les d2
on la joue avec ses 3 tous
plume ans
panique
à faire le tirage
[Musique]
toi est normal
calais 5 semble correct
entre autres trois ici ou f4 pendant
près de quatre on est bien ici sur cette
diagonale et notamment contre l'a45 je
pense que c'est pas mal mais s'inquiète
intéressant
moi
que vais-je et 3
on va prendre un g6 le fait qu'il ya un
tout petit peu le rock bon ça
la fin du monde mais
alex rios 5,5 2006
f3 ou rouges et 5
détroit peut-être aussi non
surnomme des troncs
il ya aussi qu'à l'étranger six pions
prendre pour prendre
dans le détroit
alors que les projets 6
ce
g6 qui est aussi emprise salaires pas
malin avec les faibles
de faire comprendre rouges et 5 avant
aussi peut-être ai-je fait foulée 5
juhasz 4
ouais je fais 30000 le faire donc je le
fais
tout comme toutes les pièces sont
actives derrière donc
[Musique]
ce
just do it d'un projet six ans comme ça
est-ce que j'ai sacrifié une pièce
migron
même ceux connaissez l'adage qui ne
risque rien n'a rien
celui qui risquent peut perdre mais
celui qui ne risque jamais perd toujours
bon
pas tous fous rires
une question débutante y avait quelques
locaux au moins deux coups à la fin où
ces deux housses et l'avoir bien faire
évoluer pièce qui a fait qu' il faut les
deux il faut peut être bien placer vos
pièces si vous placez si vous aidez vos
pièces un adage de l'échiquier un saint
aidez vos pièces et vos pièces vous
aiderons
voilà c'est l'adage c'est connu
c'est pas mal aidez vos pièces aux
pièces vous aiderons
et
cavalier à bouger donc alors mettez on
peut faire [ __ ] en epci suivi de
cavaliers
h 5 heure pas mal non vous prendrez vous
prend cavaliers h sem menace matt non
menaces comme les principes 6 oui
je peux faire cavalier h5
je préfère toro 3 aussi avec l'idée de
la tour 3 ensuite pourrait coulisser par
là et je peux aussi doubler les tours
mahler intéressant
vois-tu faire attention parce qu'il va
vite il va jouer ça puis cavaliers fuite
il va défendre et en même temps attaqué
la dame et ça c'est pas trés trés il ya
cavaliers 5 qui est pas mal que les
scénes pions prendre tout reprendre
cette housse à leur fort en a les
qualifs cinq gymnastes m'attend g7 la
pâte le fou qui en plus est sous
pression si les noirs prennent
il ya tout reprendre cette kim anh asmat
angers7
pour les noirs de défendre ici
la deuxième tour arrive très très vite
a three fier une pièce mais pas pour
voyager déjà deux pions potentiellement
je peux même à en récupérer un troisième
tueur même s'ils l'attaquent marche pas
j'ai 2
quand même des chances de m'en sortir au
pire quoi vous voyez je suis pas quand
même je suis pas tout à fait à poil
l'acta qui est vraiment forte
si lecavalier est sisi bouge la dame est
perdu la dame b6 est perdu si le
cavalier bouge
le cavalier psy peut pas bouger à cause
de la tacc latéral ici simplement on
prend la dame on se casse pas la tête on
a sacrifié une pièce on a récupéré
d'options la dame s'est très largement
suffisante pour la peine voilà c'est pas
la peine d'aller chercher un math ou
quoi que ce soit on prend la dame et on
lui dit à toi de jouer
voilà tout simplement voilà une belle
partie là avec un sacrifice un peu
intuitif je dirais
merci pour les explications par ne plus
jouer donc oubliez pas dans la
description de la vidéo vous avez les
liens si vous voulez être au courant des
des événements des gones al tv vous
pouvez suivre les réseaux sociaux sur
mastodonte sur des aspects aura
sur les réseaux sociaux non libre
réseaux sociaux privateurs
vous serez aussi au courant
de nouvelles
allez on joue en gros là attention en
2004 106 c'est un bon joueur voire même
un très bon joueur allait aux quatre des
six des six des six des six
être tout simplement
cali et si ça peut jouer food et 3 non
allez-vous détroit l'idée c'est de se
garder la possibilité de jouer ces trois
l'if3 met la pression sur cinq
il en va reprendre lundi
il joue g6 l'animal
j'espère jouer avec ses 3 à l'idée c'est
de contrer le fou g7 ici
par la petite structure de pions
donc on essaie de placer ses pièces en
fonction de ça
l'emport ok tout simplement
bonds est un petit jeu rock
entre autres choses mais
je le sens pas bien donc je rock ok
alors on va jouer sans doute
faucher scène c'est bien j'aime bien
puisque maintenant qu'on a joué ses
trois façons il faut que le souffle ou
sortent ici
or si h6 je recule un jeu je laisse
pousser voilà très content que les noirs
avancent leurs pions du côté de l'est le
roy on sort le cavalier on défend le 4
tranquillement
pas de stress
alors qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire ici
différents
à
je fais h3
qui maintenant f4 exactement ce que je
voulais
j'ai pas prévu
sajoo est d'amasser deux passes trop
grave je pense
et donc là on va simplement protégé aux
4 une fois de plus
alors maintenant on peut jouer sign on
ici
il se prise
à salaire intéressant
allez j'ai trop envie de le faire je le
fais
et ce prise
ok
alors est ce que je me suis trompé
pas trompé
on doit prendre
je vais laisser quatre attaques là
où va la dame
attention la dame peut pas les n'importe
où parce que il ya le fou qui attaque
ici le cavalier la donne peut pas faire
des chèques ici est le cavaly c4
semblerait que le seul coup ce soit dans
le set et dames 7
il s'auto cloulas lecavalier voilà c'est
un peu ça qui nous intéresse ici et là
j'ai l'impression que fout pranger 6 à
l'air très fort encore une fois c'est
très fils angers 6 c'est la fête au
sacrifice
on ne sait si cela
c'est la fête au sacrifice angers 6
alors d'am dam f7
possibilité
on peut faire tout reprend
et ça devrait su ça ça justifie le
sacrifice on a récupéré la pièce il peut
pas reprendre du fou et s'il prend la
dame je reprends de la tour avec une
position avantageuse
puisque j'ai un peu plus bas
ah d'accord
voilà il y va
de manière extrêmement risqué
est ce que ça marche
ce
possible que ça marche
2406 on va prendre là nul non ce qu'on a
mieux que le nul
échec à l'échec rouages 7
on a envie de prendre plus que la nul 1
tout reprend on reprend
mieux
allez on va prendre là nul j'ai
l'impression parce que je vois rien
d'autre
vois rien d'autre
pourpre en échec 3 3 6
rien allez je fais je prends la nulle
check
38 secondes il me reste
il peut tenter de la gagner un jour un
rouage suite
essayez
si fait ça hyper
à raison
et en fait nul
ah bah c'est pas mal parce qu'un prix
aussi un joueur quand même qui mieux
classique nous on a gagné d'ailleurs des
points alors s'il avait joué regarder
s'il avait joué roi à schwyz y perdez
vous remonterez l'analyse mais imaginons
qu'ils joueront ensuite alors là idc qui
répètent pas les coûts puisque c'est pas
le même courage suite que j'évite l'aria
échec au roi ce que j'avais vu hélas il
prend avec le fou il ya échec
le roi n'a pas de case il obligé de
jouer fou g7 est sûre après fou g7 d'un
projet s'est tu m'as tu vois là et
l'autre coup sûr sur échec il peut ramer
ramener la dame s'ils ramènent la dame
je prends la dame et après la prise
fouet f6 menaces mat le seul coup qui
par le matériau 6 malheureusement pour
lui le cavalier là je l'avais vue et
après fou prend il y avait deux
promettent aussi
voilà donc je vous l'avais dit s'il
avait
s'il avait jouera je suis hyper d
ok
ce parti
partis la salut à pauline pauline
courjal pauline
juin
enfin bon début de tournoi si on joue
comme ça jusqu'à la fin on sera bien
lorsqu'il va nous ce qui va ce qui va
nous poser problème dans ce tournoi
c'est la fatigue que ces trois heures et
en général à 3 m eur jeu
commencent à chuter contivo
concentration
du coup j'ai peut-être plutôt que
d'enchaîner les partis au bout de deux
heures sera pas si je ça la fatigue
venir je vais peut-être une petite pause
5 minutes plutôt que d'enchaîner de
manière à éviter de
ni aller trop vite
1300 m2 joueurs
[Musique]
pour l'instant on est content et on peut
pas on a fait des belles parties là
allez on va essayer de rester dans la
partie kiev 6 alors c4 c4 c4 au a joué
notre grand bide aps la contestent ces
derniers temps je teste un peu ça
ah ça c'est bon signe s'il se met à
réfléchir
[Musique]
ces 5
ah ça c'est
et de quatre
qu'ils prennent la dame s'il prend la
dame pour preuve deux échecs et mat
jessica les g4 n'était pas mieux
[Musique]
allez-vous prendre
après je vais je crois que c'est ce que
je vais faire
échec
pranger 3 il abandonne super bon là je
peux prendre g3 tout simplement
mais il peut il aurait pu faire carrière
trois dames bouge
bouger la tour on lui doit bouger mais
bon il est quand même pas très bien il a
des pions doublé et ça lui a pas plu il
est tombé dans le piège
le coup du berger n'incite pas tout à
fait le coup du berger mais ça y
ressemble ouais ça y ressemble
la même idée c'est d'attaquer le salua
bons conseillers pas cher ça lui en
douce m
allez on joue face à elles seules aux y
aller on va jouer avec eux quatre
aussi ce bon là je vais faire mon
antilles françaises avec détroit
calais d2
j'ai 3
e
ce cas peut-être
alif 4
[Musique]
ils menacent poussé aux cinq
allez on va pousser de 5
je vais faire cavalier 3 ou l'autre cas
mais l'autre cavaliers c'est mieux on
sort les pièces jouées des 4
on fait des 4
cavaliers et 5
calais b 3 on surprotège des 4
peu joué ces 3
ces 4
oui
avec là c'est un peu embêtant je sais
pas si faux pas
4 ici tient à les toucher 4 comme 104
prise ouais cavaliers h4 très bien
maintenant pour revenir
le four messe ag complètement oublié que
le hamels ohlala
complètement oublié mon
qui voit s'il a joué quand même un peu
moi j'ai trois
là bas c'est pas bon
c'est pas bon
faut savoir jouer avec
pris dans ces 4
que
là peut-être
qu'elles aient pensé qu'à te prends
à l'éclat leucate
at elle eu le début de partie
pas bon à foix iii ici c'est intéressant
la tacle à la tour où la d6
intermédiaire
note la dame
[Musique]
on va prendre la tour
pas une bonne partie
pour venir
bon ok allez on arrête on n'a vraiment
pas réussi le début de partie là on est
tombé dans
fait une grosse erreur en fait une en
fait une grosse erreur
complètement oublié une pièce
c'était pas très bien parti
billets cela passer à autre chose
en ce cas là dans ce tournoi alors dans
les tournois richess vous enchaînez tout
de suite les parties on n'attend pas que
tout le monde est finie donc si vous
sentez de la partie est vraiment foutu
vaut mieux pas la jouer et enchaîner
puisque le ce qui compte c'est le nombre
de points à la fin
souvent les vainqueurs sont des joueurs
qui ont joué plus de parties que les
autres d'ailleurs
des 5 ce candidat cette fois je vais
prendre en d5 plutôt que de jouer aux
qualifs 6
alors là je joue cavalier pts 6
on a appris ce qu'est ce qu'on vous ces
six là
bon là j'ai bien envie
je fais ces six îles
wi fi un pion pour accélérer le
développement
ou de 4
2,5
[Musique]
et se développer les pièces très vite
toujours aux échecs faut développer les
pièces très vite
très important
mais il faut le faire dans le bonheur
non il faut pas
tous vont se précipiter et des ordres si
vous le faites dans le bon ordre c'est
toujours mieux
alors qu'est ce qui est le coup du
berger non
alors qu'il faut que je regarde aussi le
chat switch deux coups puisque c'est en
direct sur twitter en même temps c'est
jamais
[Musique]
il faut pas que je perde trop de temps
avec ça alors d'am-dam 2
dames 2
des six
on sort les pièces en défendant hossein
puisqu'ils s'étaient d'ailleurs pourquoi
j'ai fait ça ah oui parce que je veux
menacé cavale et d4 je veux na s'est
calé des quatre attaques la dame et en
même temps menacé le pion le cavaliere 3
s'ils jouent h3k les d4
sur échec parce que là je bouge que le
roi sans doute
je lis casser la structure allait droit
on sera obligé de reprendre deux pions
avec des pions doubler ici les pions
voilà mais c'est ce qui fait d'ailleurs
tiens alors du coup ben là on joue
khaled et 4
tac la dame alors il peut faire échec
mais il faut surtout pas prendre
voilà là c'est pas grave on s'en bat
et les blancs
des problèmes à noter qu'il faut qu'il
fasse attention parce qu'ils accueillent
les princes et 2 qui pourrait arriver
aussi
ok
donc là on va prendre
je me fous
ces quatre fautes scène pardon ah ouais
ça leur gagnant ça fouette 5
il peut pas jouer cavalier ou 4 parce
qu'il ya vous prend et maintenant on
attaque f2 qui fait cavaler procès deux
échecs va gagner tous
donc presque tout
à
on fait cavaler prendre non oissel ligne
tours 1
et bien tout simplement une tour alors
on n'est pas tout à fait net parce que
s'il arrive à reprendre ce cavalier bon
ben il aura perdu que la qualité
alors ça c'est intéressant on peut
qui
fous ces deux échecs ce qui obligera le
roi à revenir
on va le faire les fous ces deux échecs
et maintenant on revienne peut-être en
g6 et leur menace de faire cavalier
chèque qui sort le cavalier de là
on va le faire tout de suite d'ailleurs
les cavaliers chèque
cavaye âge 5 on a une très belle case
pour notre cavalier ici on est quatre
et surtout notre cavalli sedo et saïf il
est sauvé ce qui rend la défense des
blancs maintenant quasiment impossible
avec une tour de moins nette
alors attention parce que ma tour de
plus elle est là et donc elle joue pas
pour l'instant
donc ça veut dire quand même qu'il
faudra trouver un moyen pour la faire
jouer
alors ici
quatre peut-être
que veulent les décades c'est bien aussi
sans votre pièce de plus on prend
les blancs ont des soucis là
wei au 2t intéressant
quand on peut
3 non
faire ça on va faire d'un v6 plus tôt
j'ai cinq ou six
l'an prochain c'est bien le gagner pions
et puis attention ça attaque le fou
souvent c'est une type de menaces qu'on
voit pas voilà il n'a pas vu
les menaces latérales un général on le
voit pas on a du mal à les voir
encore une preuve est là il ya encore
une menace ce latéral qui n'a pas vu
échec et le cavalier perdu peut pas
revenir en c2 parce qu'elle fout
avec la dame ça fait beaucoup là il va
lui manquer beaucoup beaucoup de pièces
voilà il abandonne ok allez on a réussi
à
gagner cette partie
le parti salua paquito fimo
qui commence le tournant avec 45 minutes
de retard et qui va qui nous dit qu'il
va tout faire envers sec
voilà on perd c'est que ça veut dire
qu'il va cliquer sur le bouton qui veut
lui donner deux fois moins de temps mais
qui va lui permettre de marquer un point
de plus
[Musique]
donc il y aura sans doute
leach est ce vous avez sur les chefs des
communautés équipe et vous rentrez dans
l'équipe diagonale tv il y aura sans
doute un tournoi samedi après midi
on joue black knight 2548 toi c'est du
lourd
c'est du très lourd
il joue avec ses 6 c'est à dire qu'ils
nous posent des problèmes
or on va aller on va lui envoyer la
grande barrière on pourra voir ce qu'il
fait
joue
[Musique]
allez faut 3
on va jouer que ces 4
pion évidemment regardé la paire de fou
cheikh on va simplement bien sûr couvrir
et là on va simplement de jouer sous ses
trois avec une position intéressante je
crois ici elle me fait bien cette
position j'ai la paire de fou bien sûr
en échange des données j'ai concédé des
pions doubler ici mais c'est pas
forcément très très grave
presque envie de f5 f4 pour jouer scène
très rapidement sur fous là
ça m'inquiète pas trop
peut-être que ça devrais je sais pas à
faire f 4 mais c'est qu'on va jouer cinq
rapidement et on le fait on le laisse on
le laisse s'amuser ici
on le laisse s'amuser
et ils on reprend bien sûr
ou h3 on vise
à
bon ben ok on à la colonne b pour
attaquer on est super on est très bien
ça mais attention c'est 2548 il est très
fort
donc il suffira pas d'être bien falloir
être mieux
mais on est bien alors on a une très
bonne position
or ici on peut prendre du cavalier
ou pas non 6
si on peut aller on prend du cavalier
et là maintenant baruch et avec l'idée
d'aller attaquer sur la colombe et très
rapidement alors on y va tout de suite
cette colonne b où on joue ces cinq c5
c'est mieux
beaucoup ces cinq blessures attaque la
dame et après j'ai très magnifique quasi
six superbes superbe case en d6 pour mon
cavale hausse
bons fous et magnifique prochaine coupe
des blancs c'est tombé 1
et ouais il est un peu obligé de rendre
du matériel
ce qui prouve à quel point il est en
difficulté
vingt-cinq s'échangent les dames est ce
que j'ai vraiment envie d'échanger les
dames je suis pas sûr
[ __ ] beach tour b 1
cavalier 7
allez on retrouve ainsi lors ces logis
ah oui attention un cavalier f4 assez
pénible
bon ben on va jouer ça
taquet des pièces
apprendre
cavaye h5 c'est pas mal ou c4 pourquoi
perdre le pion n'y a pas de raison de
donner un pion
oui
issifou des capots c'est commencer à
échanger des pièces
ouais il veut pas il a raison
il a raison le bougre
il a raison donc ici peut-être peut-être
tour d un du coup autour des 1 c'est pas
mal l'idée c'est simple si tout autour
des 7 et d'attaqués sur bessette
il peut tenter h5 ici je pense
le sketch du tour 17 quand même
m6 prend après il peut y perd beaucoup
beaucoup de deux pions là bas
et des menaces de ma des menaces de
couloirs des menaces de ramassage de la
tourache fuite
parce que la finale est quand même
avantageuse mais c'est compliqué de se
passer des trucs
en tout cas on voit qu'au niveau du
temps il est pas si pas si bien 1h01 36
thériault s'ils souhaitent que valeo 6
semble pas trop mal joué
alors on va jouer tour 17
ouais c'est le court il
jouer sans doute car elle et ses cinq
oui d'accord donc ici tout reprend f
cette attaque le cavaliere 4
ah ah
et là sans doute 6
ah ok matin que le
ouais ça c'est un peu embêtant j'ai pas
prévu ça
dans attend peut-être joué tour ici
qui va les prendre puis on prend
ç'a l'air pas mal
ça a l'air pas mal du tout
maintenant si projet k qui a eu cette
menace dames et cif et auront huit tours
et suite il peut ya pas moyen pour lui
de de contrôler la case aux 8
dr un à l'air en très très fort si je me
trompe pas
alors qu'elle ait des trois est possible
on va faire tourner trois sans doute
et
attention il ya le foot l'attaqué
on va reculer simplement
nancy prend
un menace d'attaquer la tour est en plus
derrière j'ai tours 8
là je me laisse peut-être f4f 4 a l'air
très fort ici
ça a l'air bon
s4 a l'air fort
ainsi bouche lecavalier il ya pis on
prend menace de faire dame voit la dame
super
on a réussi notre coup
échec
l'otan jeu plus de temps
quel dommage
plus de temps
aïe aïe aïe
quel dommage un tour de avec une
dames 2 contre une pour
haye avait joué 1
il avait joué puisqu'il à la mi-juin la
pendule que nous c'est un peu compliqué
à la fin pour gagner mais on a mieux
joué sur l'échiquier mais moins bien à
la pendule un salut à saré la ramires
dias
quel dommage cette partie des brosses tu
es une belle partie quand même allés eux
ouais on va jouer aux 5
on prendre b4 tout simplement on sur les
pièces
on va jouer connaissez 6
5 c'est bien parce que si je vous des
quatre voies la ville le fait alors mais
alors le problème de ce que ce genre de
coup c'est qu'ils bloquent ce on s'en
fout là
bien je pense
on va ok c'est sûr de ce côté là je suis
pas en vue de deux roquettes de ce côté
où il ya tout et gâteaux quais ouverts
ces quatre on va prendre
le tour est faux contre la case aux 4
je pense
oui
que les eaux cette
ouais
je fumais revenir
non mais 8
mais 4 1
j'ai fait un mauvais début de partie
pas bien parce qu'il lui laissait trop
le centre j'ai oublié de le
contre-attaqué au centre
il est pas une bonne partie
ça va pas du tout
on joue et cassis
ouah
mon bébé singe déjà
cole effet beesan pour être
normal bon ça traîne
[Musique]
ailleurs ce titi titi qu'est ce qu'on va
faire ici vous allez faut être quatre
fois que ça emmène d'autre d'intéressant
ce centre est trop fort j'aurais dû le
coup d'avant je pouvais faire [ __ ] en
f3 s'ils prenaient du cavalier j'avais
cavaliers prendre quatre pour ça j'ai
recruté deux jours au bcm trop vite
et s'il avait repris du plomb mais au
moins je lui je lui casser un peu les
droits et j'avais peut-être des options
d'ataka l'aileron
hélas
j'ai que des ennuis en fait je vérifiais
g que des ennuis
j'ai pas de gpat choses intéressantes
[Musique]
j'ai me laissent quand même ici hein
parce que je me lâche franck cavallier
ci prend du cavalier voilà alors donc là
ça va tu prends du collège prend 1,2
franck avait s'y prendre je prends au 2
tour prends et je gagne des 4
ça c'est bien quand même tu ressentes
rôle important
pas des cas puisque la fin j'ai callas
est d'attaqué
key
peut-être qu'à laisser 6
alors il ya la tour en faut
il faut prendre
on fait 3 8
[Musique]
je suis pas trop inquiet de ce coup là
parce que ça me donne la case des 5
je serais très content d'y mettre mon
cavalier je pense
le fais je peux même jouer vous aussi
d'ailleurs
je mets simplement non câblés sur cette
case et
ça c'est bizarre non
prendre la tournée n'ont pas d'âme
continuez à défendre le carré des cinq
une 33 contre 3,15 à l'est il faut que
j'accélère
je vais pas m'en sortir
on peut faire ici
dans le fond de la lidc de libérer la
case f4 pour le cavalier tout simplement
et chose simple voilà bon me laisse
c'est bon il me laisse cette case
intéresse
graphe ci prend 1,6 latour polluants b6
peut-être on va aller attaquer par là
commence à avoir quelques idées de maths
m
ces six peut-être être
fessés 6 pour contre la casse des cinq
jeux plus beaucoup de temps c'est aussi
le problème
alors tour 3,8
pour ces huit
tout de suite ça aurait été mieux
allez on va prendre
on prend
il
on prend là
bonjour c5
c'est pas grave allez hop
on prend
où
ça c'est pas mal
27 secondes tout reprend
jouer là
donc là on est vraiment pas bien
mais bon on va essayer de s'en sortir
quand même
suite
oui on va jouer avec tours 7 tant pis
il n'est vraiment pas bien
on
bien
est-ce qu'on peut sauver ça je pense pas
à cause du temps
il ne reste pas beaucoup de temps
je peux
[Musique]
elle tombe pas dans le piège
et on tombe
bon on ne peut pas
chose je sais pas quel moment on sait
nos perdu le fil
classe away après angers trop s il a ici
j'ai perdu ici le film
aurait dû protéger des cinq par ses six
plus tôt et gardés de la présence au
centre ça allait pas là ok bon allez on
en a perdu deux d'affilée là
passage à vide bon ça arrive tout le
temps à un tournoi façon il ya des
passages à vide
tournoi est long on est combien de
joueurs maintenant j'ai pas vu
on joue face à m h
[Musique]
allez on va continuer avec 4
ces cinq allées on veut faire notre
variante à base de ces quatre qui évite
les
m
permet de dérouler
un plan facile
et
et 4
k 3
et maintenant des 4
allez maintenant fait four b2
cavalli prendre des 4
cavalia 2
miné le fou là
ok d'emprunt est possible tout reprendre
cible je sais pas tout reprend un peu
doublé sur columbus si c'est bien
ce alors pas mal
alors là si
m6 était en train de réfléchir une
possibilité intéressante donc tu auras
pas
don d un
pourquoi pas de jouer
4la donc l'aï alors là ils abandonnent
un peu le centre à yves ou avec des 5
sur ce type de chose qu'est ce qu'on
peut faire on peut prendre et jouer
c'est simple non
apprendre
et jouer ces 5
[Musique]
ok crise prises
parce qu'il n'a pas fait le bon choix
faire ça je pense
doute
donc c'est pas obligé pas jouer des
quatre lui-même
tombé 1 est pas mal
les tourbains a l'air pas mal
et
s'il prend
prendre la dame
si je manquais
4 ça s'est fixé fils alors là on a un
pion pas ses protégés ce qui est mieux
comme si on passait pas protégés sous
l'oeil il est passé aussi mais n'est pas
protégé il fait qu'on peut l'attaquer et
le prendre alors que lui pour aller le
prendre c'est on va pas comment comme
salem pion qui défend avec eux des
pièces c'est plus dur en alors il faut
sacrifier une pièce et en plus le fou
son fouet sur casse blanche ne peut pas
attaquer m thurso cases noires
ça pousse à prendre ici
et apprendre là
[Musique]
donnons le jouer avec h 5 h clac pardon
ce qu'il fallait éviter
je voulais envoyer la dame mais il
fallait éviter l'échec faux ffb 5
ok
non maintenant damas deux peut-être
allez peu de pression
aussi attaque sur a7 une double pression
ici ouais bien joué sans doute
sans doute un très bon coup à jouer
damas 5
faire un échec mutuellement ici
oui
du coup
donc on va quand même jouer john b 4
2 j'aurais dû jouer dans b3 je voulais
pas jouer la montre en
phase 3
commence être embêté parce que ce pion
est très avancé
dames 1 2
à l'échec
reprendre ici en espérant faire annuler
là
pousser là maintenant
avoir deux dames allez on va prendre ici
[Musique]
échec combat on va jouer quoi on joue ça
mes échecs
là on va essayer de sauver la nul 1
tchèque
check
qui
qui veut sauver la nulle obligé de
passer là et de donner le fou
peut prendre avec échec
check
tchèque
échec
il
tchèque
et j'ai gagné autant ouais il a forcé il
aurait dû prendre là nul ou
il pouvait prendre mais sur la prairie
gagner c'est gagnant sur l'échiquier bon
ça nous ça nous rattrape de la partie
qu'on a perdu thaler autant et que son
tour c'était chaud là
salut à saré la ramires gas salut savez
là
toi
alors je vous rappelle aussi qu'il ya un
petit un petit poule à
qu'ils pouvaient répondre à ce sondage
là
jouer les tournois diagonale tv si ça
vous dit je vous le mets dans le dans le
chatt ici
voilà allez on va jouer les qualifs 6 ou
c3
le ciss du coup
2,5
des six
que 17
qu'elle prend
le prince
prend il m'attaque là on a gagné on a
gagné on a gagné enfin de gagner on n'a
pas gagné mais on a gagné quand même
comme ces sept ici sans doute
m6
attends quoi provoquer
c'est bien
je saigne
avec l'atr ça prend plus
ça m'intéresse plus
peut pas toucher 5 ici cavaliers prend
peut-être joué avec m6
je vous avais qu elle 6
[Musique]
les 5 c 4
jouer 5
[Musique]
la leaf ou 17
poussez 6
des six des six otages et c5
bah je me suis un peu affaibli un
vêtement
à terrible à ce que j'ai fait
allez on va prendre aussi
ouais on va prendre
est-ce que je prends à f3
[Musique]
or c'est vite
pour prendre
et
tous trois huit c'est un peu poussif là
je joue de manière un peu poussive passe
pas terrible terrible
alors ici tour
pour cette tout simplement
le 5e livre saint cloud ce nom
on fera pas de case là ils menacent de
jouer quatre comme un nuage est
peut-être celle du coup
à terme c'est pas terrible
à lévis pour donner un peu d'air à mon
fou parce que là ils menacent eux quatre
ils menaçaient de me l'enfermer se fout
ok donc là on va simplement reculer
quand la tour
[Musique]
touriste y avoir à peu près
c'est pas byzance mais mais ça va
alliage théâtre
le pas
deux parties là c'est je me suis un peu
emballé après avoir gagné le pire on a
bien joué
il faut pas craquer
il faut attendre un peu la faute
sorte
tu veux pousser mille tonnes
f5 et sait pas c'est pas le c'est pas
top
voilà un héros des six
tours c7
2 simplement je reviens j'ai qu'une 08
encore une fois
quand difficultés autant on va répéter
s'il est d'accord pour répéter moi aussi
maintenant tous ces sept c'est pas bon
tour c'est cette c'est pas bon the town
le pion
tu as trop faim
ta strophe
je peux peut-être la sauver encore mais
j'ai quand même pas choisi le
choisi la meilleure façon de la jouer
vraiment dommage
allez il faut prendre ici
maintenant on va commencer à les ont
joués 5 ont commencé à créer à essayer
de créer un peu de contre aux jeux
aller loin si on peut pas sûr qu'on
puisse 1
je sais 6
qu'est donc mon
rien fait on va rien faire aussi on va
attendre onze secondes après il va
m'avoir longtemps y'a pas moyen à les
prises
échec
et ce prise
allez
on voit le roi on va les chercher ce
pion
ou f3
sûr d'être allé s'est perdu
c'est perdu perdre autant bien joué et
jouent à lui on était sous pression
ça fait partie du jeu c'est ça le
problème on bits comme ça sans ajout de
temps si on est dominé comme ça sur la
position ce qui était le cas
chercher à avoir trop de trop de choses
on est après avoir damé le pion j'aurais
dû consolider en fait et g
prix trop confiance
et donc après on est sous pression on
prend du temps et à la fin mais voilà ce
qui arrive on perd autant
donc il faut ça faut maintenir en rythme
boye en général c'est ce qui se passait
comme l'adversaire si l'adversaire est
un peu plus fort que vous
mais même si sur l'échiquier vous avez
l'impression que vous tenez vous quand
vous passez plus de temps à la fin mai
ça suffit pas
non on répète moi aussi
[Musique]
jouy ça
obligé de le faire tout de suite dans là
je prends
au lieu 200 doute ici
et maintenant b4
donc là évidemment prendre du faux pour
pas
pour pas laisser notre fou enfermés
derrière ses pions ok il est parti
alors est-ce qu'on peut jouer ces cinq
ici est ce que c'est bien
peut-être passé 5
4 est possible et on joue à quatre 4 à 5
à 6 il pourra pas prendre puisqu'elle
fouilles attaque on prend un peu d'air
ici
ou fcm voilà je veux pas voilà j'ai pas
envie de donner mon fou de défense au
fou du roi et sans droits
on l'a sans doute il faut prendre
et ici à l'air pas mal
cavalière 4 a l'air pas trop mal
rendre ici les changes il a il a plu
voilà milla plus défenseur du roi
donc sans voir un peu plus fait que le
mien de ce fait
alors
[Musique]
mais
certains
je n'ai pas envie qu'il façade
alors je fais un petit piège mais elle
tombe dans un piège manquer
donc donc donc donc
d2
g4
artificiel comme le coup mais il pouvait
pas prendre parce que s'il prenait il y
avait tout reprend et fuite suivi de
dames trois fous
quel coût 17 bon
et 5
six dames 2
échec
hi fi canon attention vous jouez
toujours h3 ici
toro un
parent
et équilibre j'ai pas réussi à profiter
du truc
[Musique]
ouais
ça ça perd au moins deux pions échec
derrière
et on prend
et
de hockey ou mais ça permet de faire
échec
j'aime bien plus
tu es le roi
ita
on bloque les pions n'a pas de couleur
voilà l objet de jouer ça ça c'est mort
et finit là
finale 2 pions et gagnante ça s'est joué
vous avez un tout petit pied en un
passage en finale
donc il avait sans doute une position
légale
ça suffit
voilà simplement la dame de gagner
tranquillement
et il abandonne ok allez qui dictent war
s'aiment pas il reste une heure 27
ce que les blancs ne sont pas
désavantagés par le temps
faut d'abord expliquer ce qu'est la
cadence 10 au final la cadence s'est
donc c'est le sait le temps qu'on a à la
pendule pour la partie donc là ici on
est on est sur une liste soit essais
marqués en haut à gauche
ces cinq + 0 ça veut dire que ces cinq
minutes chacun donc cinq minutes pour
les blancs cinq minutes pour les pour
les noirs
et + 0 ça veut dire qu'il ya pas d'orage
ou de temps alors que quand on fait un
par exemple 1 3 + 2 on a trois minutes
pour les bleus rentrent trois minutes
pour les noirs et +2 à chaque achat
cours en rajoutent deux secondes à la
pendule
ce qui fait que ça évite d'être jamais à
court de temps on peut toujours jouer du
moment que je joue en moins de deux
secondes on a un petit rajout de temps
qui ce qui s'opère allez je vais jouer
avec ses 5 un peu pour changer mais cinq
[Musique]
dams et 2
des six jeux peu con
bon coup là mais bon tant pis allez hop
g6
et
g7
le fait qu'ils jouent f4 là je sais pas
si ça allait fois ci c'est ici
toutefois s'ils s'avancent à lui aurait
compliqué la reprise du pion
c'est dommage
alors d'un v6 tomber 8
ces 4
qu'elle décède sans doute ici
je libère mon faux
et je rapatriement cavaliers
à alors là
c'est classique ça
donc jouer
8 allée pression maintenant comment ça
fait un peu la pression sur b2t plat on
a un grand vide un coq est pas un gambit
puisque
on a là on a presque la renault on n'a
pas la colonne ah bon mais on a on n'a
pas d'eau ni pion aux que dans le
camping où par définition on donne un
pion
adama think thank
pour ces huit
vous prend
on en prend
tout reprendre
assez intéressant ces deux tours
holmes
pas si c'est intéressant pas après j'ai
pu m'en fous de cases noires samedi ça
m'embête un peu
ça m'embête un peu
on va jouer avec à l'essai 7
et c'est cette ça met la pression sur le
centre ça d'abord ça recentralise un peu
mon cavalier
éventuellement il pourrait venir en b 5
pour attaquer ses 3 mais aussi pour
viser la case ici
casse des 4
alors là ce qu'on peut pas jouer le 6
puis on prend pions prend et on a un
gros centre apparemment qui est en train
de se former
cavalli 6,4 milliards d'âmes à 6
tenir à peu près aussi ce pion prendre
pions prend que l'essai qu'adama 6 ouais
ça a l'air intéressant
alléché au cices
et dame à 6
six parce que ça ça clown tout petit peu
ici même ciel qu'avait laissé 3 mais
surtout sa défense des six ça c'est
important quand même il a oublié une
carrément guînes pièce
on va la prendre
on prend les pièces
prends les pièces mode aux mains
il faut il faut surtout il faut jouer
vite c'est horrible ce jeu
il faut des 4
il y apprend échec et en même temps à
gagner la tour s'il prend le fou je
prends de la dame et du coup ça échange
les dames
hu
intéressant
c'était pas
check
dam des quatre clouage du cavalier
attaques de la dame
vva
une 46 contre une tranquille faut
absolument que je j'accélère mon rythme
de jeu est prise
donc je prends pas donc on va nous on va
prendre
et on va prendre b2 bien sûr
alors ça c'est intéressant mais y'a st
prendre ici on va jouer roger sept ont
évité de se faire enfermer le roi
toujours je sais tout de suite
d'ailleurs allez hop détroit
peut-être se faire mater là
cavalli là ya pas de maths donc on va
jouer des deux
pas de maths sur clavel et j'évite les
rouages ça il n'y a pas de cavalier pts
6e heureusement way airways 5 il n'y a
pas de calais 6 puisqu'elle cavaliers 17
sinon il faisait il faisait nulle part
répétition ok donc là maintenant il ya
échec
dames
et c'est bon la partie est finie
black is willing g4
d'en prendre
c'est terminé
ok merci à juanes
ce marseille
allez maintenant on vient de marquer
deux fois il faudrait marquer pour
marquer les quatre points maintenant
aller au jeu vous face à paquito fille
mon paquet au film qui viennent me
bercer quai oui il m'a fait un berserk
donc il est tombé à 2 minutes 30
donc si je tiens bon rythme
on peut le
on peut gagner cette partie
dix prises
ou 3 et bien
sans doute ici
pas mal dam des deux
problème on revient ce sont son cavalier
pas bien je gagne en temps le en le
chassant
on s'est reconcentré ici voilà on va
chasser simplement ce cavalier
[Musique]
voilà
tombé 1 on va jouer envoyez b4
lors des quatre il va non il va nous
embêter
son prendre des cinq j'ai pas envie
pendant mes cinq ans est
la prêtrise prise en c4 bon on va
prendre tant pis ça me ravit pas en fait
mais bon c'est comme ça
tout de même
non je veux nous sommes tout de suite
on gagne et tout de suite
oui
[Musique]
prend 1,6
j'avais au sein qui attaque et
lecavalier 6 et en même temps attaqué là
bas j'ai raté sa roue mais ça fait rien
faria on a comme une bonne partie
toujours
du tout là
on joue et b4 on prend un peu d espace
allez le dame
prends toujours un peu d'espacé l'ale
dame
et encore de l'espace al dawa
il faut avancer les pions passé et puis
ont passé sont faits pour être avancée
web 6
si je garde ce four
vous
qu'il est meilleur que le sien kita dans
le vide
il a un oeil sur de ce côté là où j'ai
quand même un pion même s'il n'a pas
encore un oeil tout à fait sur le
aurait pu jouer fois c est aussi un
tours siens ça se passe à l'aide d'amis
si à cause de notre pions passé
si ça a été joué
pour ces six
peut-être b si c'est bien
il sait bien
b4 bien ici sans doute
que les d4 allez les noirs sont en
grande difficulté ici avec ce pion qui
les fixe en plus ça les dames
ils sont fixés la wii du g2 obligé de
lâcher le pion des six ça c'est une
catastrophe pour les
pour les noirs maintenant de 5
catastrophique ça libère maintenant m'en
fous j'ai deux allées si les blancs ne
font pas de bêtises devrait remporter
cette partie
tout est là faut pas faire de
ces 6
allez non bessette c'est plus fort bien
sûr et maintenant fois c'est terminé
rideau ah non j'ai vu j'ai pas
je vais pas anticiper correctement
où j'ai failli faire tour c1 il ya
cavaliers ou deux
on a huit alors bien ça suffit
pense
parce qu'il peut pas avec le roi il peut
pas approcher à cause du pion tour à 8,6
férois 17 aura lui le roi peut pas venir
protéger la tour à cause du pion des 6es
regarder m'a bercé qu'ayant donc il a
plus de temps il me reste deux minutes
une position perdante
réussi à bella je suis content parce que
on a marqué les quatre points ça y est
on a réussi trois parties d'affilée donc
ça c'est pas mal ça c'est bien alors il
ya deux mille huit cent soixante
quatorze joueurs en 2008 174 on est 57e
attention on joue un bon joueur à 2300
la de nike director attention
ces dix joueurs que les mettre où les
grands maîtres hésita à beerse etc et ça
ça commence à être des joueurs qui
jouent
commence à jouer sérieux
2 4
l'ips 6
on joue avec des 5
au cices
ar 5
des six
c'est simple sans doute ici
et ce prix vise à les prises
[Musique]
prise
qui sait si ça tacle puis
peu
[Musique]
mt 6
attaque le pion aux 4 à noter que
carrillo ça ne marche pas parce qu'il y
avait du prendre des 4
à comment ils protègent ça
poussés aussi ce que je prend peut-être
ouais
6 pouces je prends et après j'ai une
grosse cazals 4 s'il fait ça parce qu'il
va pas faire çà et là il ya un vrai
problème parce que si je joue j'ai 3 il
ya prise il ya le il ya tout reproche
trois derrière
notre ami est un peu en difficulté là
c'est pas tellement le et alors là je
prends sans hésiter
je suis protégé par mon fou pire là ça
me donne une super grosse kazan leucate
et le jour où ils veulent à chasser par
f3 et s'affaiblit beaucoup beaucoup de
cases
comment y allait envoyer tout de suite
sur cette très belle case 4
mais cinq
oui
12,5
tous les ans le 4
esprit
aussi fou
mouche pas
ferrand
tout doux
what to do what to do what to do what to
do faire quelque chose surtout pas trop
traîner
deux sets de 7
pas très convaincu par ce qu'on met à
houla cavaliers prendre puis on prend
d'un prof ou prend un échec reprend
damas 4
ouais
ce que je peux pas faire le
qui si ça ne peut risquer
g6 tout simplement
6 pour faire le petit roy
peut-être je sais pas non c'est pas ça
me plaît pas non plus
peut-être tour des mythes
pour des 8
[Musique]
puis sont un peu complexe pour très
complexe
le point c'est que j'ai pas envie de
rock et parce que si j'avais rockets il
ya des matchs 5 voilà ok maintenant
qu'il fait et fait que les f3 hockey
qui trop qu'intéressant
ouais
ok
qui
[Musique]
j'essaie maintenant puisque
peu
ça me plaît me plaît je fais g5 brusquer
mai
et sans doute très risqué tant pis
cavalier prendre pour prendre
[Musique]
être dans macadam macadam à 4
1 4
[Musique]
pompe
je 4
j'étais pions prendre pour tout
reprendre
chaque
allez
je vois pas quoi faire d'autre de toute
façon il me reste une 8,3
sans doute prendre
là il y alors s'ils jouent cavaillon 5 à
tour ses sept sinon il faut qu'ils
prennent en c6 d'abord si voilà
d'accord d'accord
on l'est tous reprend
[Musique]
2 8e
le plus d'un
et trois fois sauvé 6
allez on le prend
je vous ragez 7
quel jeu tour 17
deux secondes contre
2 6 mais encore un peu en difficulté là
au niveau du temps mais bon
pour
entre jef 4
il m'a donné une belle case pour mon
cavalier
ok donc la up
c'est pas s'il fait pas un peu exprès là
parce que l'impression que
parce qu'une pression qui va se faire
mater s'il continue
échec gagne at war
o pour que j'ai fait
pis le les coups qu'il fallait pas haut
mais tant pis ok bien joué par lui voilà
il m'a mis la pression autant surtout
dans une position où il était sans doute
un peu mieux
bien que ce soit pas décisif
il a bien joué allez bonne partie alors
c'est 6
et si je voulais c'est 4 à l'est
oui la panne en flammes ils d'accord il
rentre dans une
où
pas sûr que ce soit un très très bon
coup ou là
un tempérament agressif
si sans doute
si j'ai quatre ce qu'elle fout
donc
mais comme dit l'autre
de masques
à trois menaces de jouer b4 tout
simplement
b4
dans un bouge quelque part
il m'a donné tout le
tout l'attirail la prise
prise
et à la fin d'un pion
[Musique]
on a gagné un pion
alors
ou 3
v4 possible
peut pas prendre
puisqu'il ya deux pièces d'un mais fou
qui protège au quai à 5
5 tombé 1
zone de le laisser ouais je vais 5g pas
raison de lui c'est la colonne à
s'ouvrir
pas de raison de le lycée du contre
je suis mieux aller le roi
plus on est de plus
alors
pour bien
patient je menace pions prend voilà
hockey fait d'un v6
donc il se laisse complètement envahir
dans les pions blancs
saint clar très fort ici
il
yes ici
un petit piège intéressant
si je prends
l'afu pranjic
eh bien
on va simplement
pas simplement de déplacer leurs eaux un
peu voilà là je me laisse deux mois là
ok alors ces cinq prises prise lequel
n'a plus de 15 le croire
en position
allez on fait ces cinq
ce pas
fait je me suis un peu trompé hun sen
bon et on va prendre l'a d'abord
pas normal et on prend quand même il
peut quand même prendre le fait qu'il y
ait pas échec c'est pas ça change pas
grand chose mais quand même prendre ces
troncs
mais bon ça fait rien on prend ici nous
et attention parce qu'à bessette
khattak roll
tournon qui peut pas tout faire ce qu'il
veut avec saddam ou alors s'il peut mais
va perdre
du matériel
sife est d'alger 3 il suffit de
le fou ici et ensuite il pourra pas
empêcher des sept voiles à jouer un truc
dans ce style là
on fait tous ses cadres pour viser le
pion à vii menace des dommages 5
et que le 5 pas mal
qu'est donc on va jouer un ou deux
enfin on est chez
ici
ce que l'on mettra le roi long
que
2 3
nouvelle fou
en question c'est où balfour le cas à
lille empêche de bouger et là aussi elle
qui ont qui l'empêchent de revenir
donc il n'a pas de cazin semble-t-il un
échec
sur le roi dollar
peut aller bien et contrôle toutes les
cases blanches l'art ici
oui on sait qu'il a trouvé sur lui
ça c'est dangereux
hi hi hi hi chèque je pas du tout eu
le patron
heureusement son footballeur aurait fait
un échec
là
les comètes aux cavaliers
en espagne je me fais maths et à ces
horribles
[Musique]
c'est un joli matin
tous vu la contre attaque je n'ai pas
fait attention
ça c'est la mauvaise défaite de la
journée
ouf
durand
tyrone speed bonjour très bien joué sans
doute la partie d'avant est
run speed
allez
c'est parti
4 elle a maintenant faut essayer
d'enchaîner quelques que je fasse une
petite pause là quand même
me prend
mt 6
très mal déroulée
ça me va
des cinq sets
gagnent autant
6 c'est dans
au set rapidement
ça c'est bizarre
on va quand même jouer faux s'est
rapidement
à
dressant un v6
sors de là parce que
bourgoin
or when sortir maintenant
on
à 4
à 4 4 à 4 que les 17 sur 5 g dames à 7
ou c5 c5 pas mal fini
sur 1 5 to damas est ça va ça a l'air
d'aller à l'essai 5
si cinq succès pour revenir ici aussi en
k 2 à 5
il d'autres biens
reprise
mort
aussi
qualité 3
l'un des trois fous des cadres est
possible
bien fou des quatre sauvegarder le fou
parce que ça met une pression un peu sur
cette ligne
info 3 hockey
ou 3
3 x 3 x 3
pour 2,8
pour prendre
alors peut-être sortir nos pièces du
coup je fais qu'aller 17 ou pas
de tous ces 6 et 17 sur les pièces
qui joue pas
ok
la dame c6 menace mat
allez on menace mat
va pas être trop mauvais sens ouais
on apprendrait que les c5 ceci prend je
reprends et je gagne un tempo
apparemment à cause du
des chèques la découverte sur le roi
minutes contre 3,16
ok
cavalier 5e dame b 6
avec des idées là
avec des idées d'autant que
le four b3 et emprise
ouais
jouer sans doute b4
alors
jouer les 3
jouer un truc là
de listings
alors il faut pas
p
cavaliers detroit
ou cavaliers prend le taureau
marche pas
faire coller aux 4
qui nous lie à tour d2
ne me
[Musique]
il ya même des six tient coi jeu ou
petit très compliqué hein
ce qui m'agace c'est la rapidité avec
laquelle il joue c'est ça qui me
j'arrive pas bien je sais pas comment
ils font nettement
hop
son âme est rouillée date où vivent deux
sans doute
ah et ça marche pas à tous les deux il
ya cavaliers j'ai complètement oublié
cavaliers au oui l'a pas vu il l'a pas
vu l'animal
ça me permet de gagner le pion
heureusement qu'il n'a pas vu
à tour été en prise par le cavalier n'a
pas vu madame est défendu
bon mais j'ai fini par gagner
péniblement un pion
ça n'a pas été simple suis pas sûr de
pouvoir regarder par ailleurs
pour ici aussi garder le pion
et donc là d'être peut-être fou fou ici
bouger
pression
les prend on va prendre une bonne partie
attention donc on va jouer j'ai six ont
envie de me prendre un match du couloir
il me reste que 12 secondes c'est
injouable c'est vraiment jouable
c'est injouable elle est calée c3 ou la
la il a mis son fou en danger
je risque plus avoir de plus avoir de
presque plus à ne plus avoir de point
pour finir
jouer clio 4
échec
mange pas
bien là
prendre c'est fini je perds autant
une minute de retard
une petite pause de quelques secondes
revenir au tournoi c'est un peu
difficile à aller petite pause parce que
ça fatigue
haas a redémarré ah oui j'ai pas fait
attention heureusement que j'allais
perdre une peut-être déjà non pas les
qualifs 6 c4
[Musique]
allez on va jouer avec cinq essais de
faire une partie d'attac
que j'ai 4
alors ici fou
ces 5
on encaissé 6
m
rand pions
moi c'est mon cas
[Musique]
pour 1,6
on vient ici
même s'ils jouent ces 5 spare rame en
recul maintenant ils peuvent en premier
avec ses pions
on va voir ou alors ça me permet de
jouer des six de sortir mon fou
de bonnes conditions
d'autres
wouah
des six
on attaquera la page 2
ouais
[Musique]
notre peuple le kava l'os
ah ça ça tombe bien
ça donne un pion si je ne m'abuse
il faut sortir le fou de la dame de
l'âge est pas là mais 37,6 à calais des
quoique
qu'elle ait des 5 d'hommes des six
mais bon tripoli où il veut ça mais peut
également
le jouer comme suit
tranquille
alors d'être repoussé six maintenant
[Musique]
khaled et saint cloud et 6
vous voulez bien
j'attendais de le mettre en dc ce qui
bouge ce cavalier parce qu'il avait mis
en 1 4 après je regagnais intentions fou
alors dames c'est trop attention parce
que là il veut il peut viser 7 ce
matelas
aymen à 7,4
et amath
on va jouer six tout simplement dans une
note
et contrer cette petite batterie là
f4
rex 4 f4f 4 4 c'est bien car c'est bien
donc on va jouer cavalier
[Musique]
g6 bien que cavalier f7
2 les sets
[Musique]
pas mal
comme j'ai 4
nomme g3
attention maintenant s'il me bouge lama
tanger de cause du fou
au matin m amat maths et demi
o2 alors faut faire attention à des
sacrifices ici maintenant
pour ça que je vais
il fait celles qu'elle prend 1,7
[Musique]
on va prendre et en transe ce truc là
parce que ça m'agace
à
il fait tout reprend se trompe pas de
passif reprend
pourquoi il faut pas se tromper
honnêtement
c'est bizarre
on va se
pour éviter d'être attaqué par le fouet
libérer un peu dans le cavalier s'il
avait pris du fou il y avait foule pour
un f4 peut-être après pions prendre
d'apprendre qu'on prend à la faim de
gagner à tour ou un truc comme ça
pas trop
tous rêvent 5
où ça sorte se classe pas possible
5 c'est pénible parce que
fawcett
l'idée c'est de bien protéger cette case
parce qu'il menaçait peut-être de
prendre avec la batterie là
lui remet
là maintenant je peux je peut menacer
peut-être ok on va vous prendre
sapeur tranquillité
alors la question qu'on peut se poser
c'est tout rejet des taux qu'est ce qui
se passe surtout g5y 6 6 puis on prend
il peut faire dame pranger cet os 6
voilà donc là il fait échec simplement
donc quand les coups sont faciles suffit
de jouer vite
auj
26 hockey
m6 dames 6
si c'est pas fou d66 il n'y a pas
6 mai à tours 3 6
où la dame
ça protège ça évite les sacrifices en
abscisse
et sur dame des sept voiles on la
surnomme simplement de tours l'un est
c'est fini je crois que là maintenant il
ya menace ici c'est fini avec échec
c'est fini à condition de finir dans les
temps
voilà donc là on gagne la dame on va
jouer 6 6 pour empêcher la tour de
revenir la tour est perdu ici lé manager
si c'est la torre est foutu
on devrait gagner cette partie c'est pas
facile surtout il joue vite quoi c'est
terrible
4-4 on va jouer chez 6
la tombe vide
fier
brice prisé sur foot roya dame prend 1,4
peut-être à metz je n'ai pas croyable il
m'a eu à cheikh donne la tour
il a quand même réussi à avoir un chèque
échec
échec et mat
ok c'est dur les points sont difficiles
à gagner un fond vous et que
salut à trinity salut trinity
aller au tour au tournoi
les 118 allée notre objectif ça à l'ide
on va essayer de finir dans les sens ça
sera très bien
il va percer quand il m'a bercé qu'est
il sait que je suis fatigué sais rien
mais
on va croire qui sait on va essayer de
l'avoir à l'usure du coup persique et ça
veut dire que donc il a accepté de
il a accepté de
rendre
2 minutes 30
près de prise
qu'on peut pas jouer t4 ici ainsi
[Musique]
descotes c'est super
que veulent les prendre
cavalier d2
on leur fout et 3 qui
iep ou trois semaines
calais prend et sinon ouais ça va les
prendre
et 5
il peut pas jouer jusque là tout de
suite il aurait prise prise
mais bon on va
j'ai pas envie qu'ils me fassent f4
hockey
[Musique]
ces cinq ici est possible
grosse avancée à l'el dame
que les pcistes
[Musique]
si c'est logique
des cas très logique éliminer le
défenseur du roi c'est toujours bien
4 reprendre la dame parce que si je
prends du cavalier comme cali ou 3
bronze
même pas je prends du cavalier
je prends du cavalier sur lequel les
trois guichets que je prends du cavalier
et puis je fais non je crois que la dame
un centralisme adam
aussi sain
pour b 6 avec simplement l'idée tour b 1
qui tombe bien du coup
là on touche jouée ces six il peut pas
prendre parce que la tour est perdu la
dame est attaqué il est en grande
difficulté 1
parce qu'ici ça serait étonnant qu'il
s'en sorte
allez je
si on a une minute de plus à cause du
bersac
attention puisqu'il menace voilà donc on
va prendre tout simplement on prend avec
l'échec
on prend avec échec
ok
on joue cavalier des 4
[Musique]
cavalli princes 5 est possible
tout reprend suffit pour 38 fille
c'est cette menace de fleur d'âme
la bombe nous a il a fait un père c'est
qu'il a un peu surestimé ses capacités
là on se rapproche des 100 premiers
c'est bien 3500 soucier norme c'est en 1
3574 joueurs
vous imaginez 3574 joueurs
on les met dans une salle cela alors on
va jouer allez on va recommencer avec 4
ces 4
mais ces 3
j'ai deux
valeo 2
c'est un début qui demandent pas trop de
connaissances théoriques donc
intéressant
détroit
est ce que je fais ou g5 ici
bon je continue plan classe
je fais tourner en 3d 4
pourquoi vous êtes 4 pour l'instant donc
pas de panique
on peut toujours pas
on compte céder 4
plantation si fébé sicilia pions prince
f5 avec le fou khattak
faisable parce qu'ils pourraient faire b
6 puis on prend fou prend et sacrifié
volontairement la qualité avec des cases
blanches affaibli dans ce cas là je
prends pas la qualité oui ça me déplaît
fortement
et donc je le fais pas
[Musique]
ok
bon là j'ai pas le choix faut que je
prenne
et il faut faire fou prend le foot pour
remplacer le pion je pensais en g3 donc
je pensais pas trop trop de temps
je pense que ça va
voilà tout simplement toucher 3
moi bien
où j'ai 4
de 4 poules de 4 poules de 4 4 c'est pas
mal alors je peux pas jouer f3 cavale et
maintenant ça marche pas toujours f4
parce que sinon il va me planter un truc
en f3
faivre 4 vs 4 pour protéger la case f3
en fait avec la tour f 4 ça va assez
bien défendu s'est défendu trois fois
j'étais un peu obligé de faire ça parce
que sinon je suis me planter un truc
arrive trois ça peut commencer à pouvoir
devenir dangereux là ça va pas oublier
qu'il a quand même donné un pion pour
cette histoire là
donc là on joue et d'amd 2 se déroule le
cavalier
quand même intéressant
ok
d'autres tours f2 ici
je fasse attention
l'animal l'aï nous nous embête un peu là
quand même
prise vous prend
ou f2 et je vais
près de 4
prend il vous prend un échec
bref deux ans fou voilà
ou prendre on apprend
gk
n'est ce pas grand chose une impression
donc je vais prendre les je prends
j'ai l'impression que ça va
faire attention parce que
peu des pièces ici mais ça va je crois
que j'ai assez de défense
27 contre 3 01 hockey là je reprends
j'avais vu pour lui j'ai vu deux hommes
g4 bien sûr
mais ça m'inquiète pas trop je vais
faire cavalier 2 pour chasser ce que ce
fou sans doute
libé scène peut-être je sais pas ok donc
la dame g4
donc la cave a lieu 2 sainte
certainement
fait curieux 2
tout ça défend f4 ça attaque sa défense
g3 donc ça peut pas être ça peut pas
être monnaie m être mauvais jeu
menaçante de prendre f4
ça doit ça doit être correcte
ça doit être correcte
le doute si je crois je
on sait c'est maintenant cette tour qui
s'activent faut pas oublier pour avoir
cette initiative coordonnée un pion
donc s'il n'arrive pas à le retrouver
son pion à la fin on va finir par
comptez
si on prend ces cinq qui ont prendre ce
slk voilà il s'en va mais si samba ça me
permet de prendre ces 5
là et de prendre en bessette
attention on peut quand même ici
j'ai très bien défendu on fait ici un
avec la dame le fou le cavalier sur f 4g
trois défenseurs la peine deux
attaquants un troisième est actuellement
et encore donc je peux très bien doubler
les tours
et après
si tu es sont fous là peut-être
je vous donnais 3 au site est possible
kessé sapiens après derrière il peut y
avoir des attaques de maths quelle
poisse 4
tout ceci ne mène à rien
dames 3 sans doute tout simple
attends attends attends
y'a pas à ces trois là
le dob attaque il
la tour ok
tome 3 pas de pas de panique
on défend
tout ceci est très bien défendu
et 5
5 sans doute
[Musique]
je songe aussi à prendre aussi
dams tron
en cas de prison prend
[Musique]
une 18 contre 36 avant du temps j'ai
regardé la pendule un peu ouais c'est ça
qui me faisait un tout petit peu peur
et non pas tant que ça
doublé tout simplement
is
s'y prend il va perdre le four
oui
et si prendre la tour il va
malheureusement pour lui se faire mater
voilà tu te trouvais ça
si on prend on se mange pas
donc il faut jouer c'est sans doute plus
simple qu'avec des scènes tranquille
mais c'est dans le cinq échecs
ah tiens
et ici simplement va clouer voilà encore
la dame
on va jouer maintenant tour en bessette
tour en sept
et on a gagné là je menaçais cavaliers
pts 6 avec le fameux matelas
je m'attendais à faire ça s'il avait
joué tour et suit simplement prend 1,7 à
une pièce de plus plein pion de plus
tout va bien alors le petit initiative
mais en fait il a suffi de deux joué
solide et ne pas s'emballer
et attendre que ça que ça se décante
bon mais c'est bien aller aux 4 il reste
20 minutes sylvain approche du bout on
approche du but
aller aux quatre des cinq
la petite pause m'a fait du bien une
minute de pause caleb 6
à
simple non allez sec
les b 4
des six
f5 sans doute
échec
on prend le fou
allez qu'elle et ses 6
du cloud est en fait il aurait dû clouer
iphone 4 regrettez vous le connaissez si
ce que j'ai fait
6 peut-être
l'idée c'est de sortir par là
que l'échec
louise attaque le pion à la somme dont
un pion échec
le put rien deuxième pont
qui complet un deuxième pion
kra coût total de l'adversaire
cheikh eux
tout est possible ici je sais pas où
aller chez que ça a l'air bien quand
même
échec
on prend
je
enfin là
on
f5
on joue avec ses 6
ouais ouais
mais avec quoi
pour empêcher
moi de là
chez menant tout droit
et moi je vais scène pour fixer les
pions sur noir on va vouloir les prendre
avec notre fou sans doute
me choix avec un v6
maskrey manquions passé
allez on va jouer qu'à 5
on
il
pour 2,8
complètement foutu cette position
[Musique]
on va jouer
ça
rendre ici
heureusement saluer on va manger tous
les autres pions
aussi peut nous arranger un paquet on
marque un
tête nue de cette histoire là du coup
prise prises il faut prendre je pense
il
il s'est trompé
g8 et ce n'est pas cette petite pas si
clair en fait
excédé foot que leur poser cette
histoire a laissé cinq
il y en a trois ou quatre pions
de purs mon ami
on ne donne rien pas de raison nous
donner quoi que ce soit
pas d'horizon de lui donner quoi que ce
soit
à genève on se fait rien
ouais
abandonner avant mais le fait perdre du
temps je suis sûr qu'ils y en a qui
jouent en équipes qui marquent les
points les autres ils ont pour mission
d'en ralentir les autres bombes ont fini
bien là on finit bien aller reste
quatorze minutes on et 61e l'objectif de
finir dans les 100 premiers est atteint
et on pourrait pourquoi pas viser les 50
premiers
avec un peu de un peu de réussite
[Musique]
2 345
oui alors à temps ouais calais 6
h3 d'à côté
h3 d'accord ou kefu 17 pouces et 6
yahia
quand aucun
il alors de jouer ça
très facilement ans tommy
notre 1001ha les pages 6
1 6 pour ralentir un peu
non c'est pas bon dans un seul et pions
2-4 quelque 4 cavaliers aux 4
ouais
calais prend on prend cavaliers pts 6
allez que les prend
qu'alexis top 4
vincent
m6
ouais
c'est vrai que c'est un peu pénible
il joue bien il joue bien
il joue bien
je suis pas sûr qu'on arrive à la sauver
celle là
il a bien joué
il faut 17
ouais
on est très très pas bien mal aller h5
on va tenter quelque chose de ce côté là
sinon je vois pas bien ce qu'on va faire
je joue h 4 ok
qui sinon je vois je table d'abord
besset l'on va faire cavaler prendre je
fais ça parce que je vois rien d'autre
en fait
alors h4 non on va faire d'un prends je
prendre au moins deux pions
voilà je prends deux pions pour la pièce
le tap la tour
pas le grand luxe mais
a pris 2,5
en fait s'ils souhaitent
[Musique]
que j'ai 4
donc j'ai vite
échec
on va récupérer un deuxième pion
ça c'est très bien
key
alors sous
post 6 tu n'en faut cette année fawcett
j'ai fait le bon choix je
je
sinon j'étais un peu
cui
un peu qu'on y est allé h3
je passe quelque chose
ou sept
jouer avec
non on va attendre un peu joué avec acea
sem non plus ça ne sera pas
peut jouer avec ça tient
pour d'autres c'est intéressant
ce que s'il fait s'il fait on rêve de la
tour échec
et si revient donc ça attaque le fou et
s'il revient je répète voilà donc là du
coup estime cookies
qui est un peu embêtant je pense pour
lui
ouais
ok ça c'est pas mal
avec b 6
après ce prise
moi je voulais qu à 5
ont joué avec flo suite
prison b4
prise
tous riches est qu on est pas mal on est
pas mal
on n'est pas mal du tout
sûr que ça gagne mais ça fait au moins
un nul qu'est ce que je fais je prends
la new look est ce que je fais
si un nul je sais pas trop je sais pas
je ne sais pas ce qui se passe
échec
tous ces 5
je
et ces mains thiès au le matt aut le mat
alors qu'on n'était pas bien longtemps
là il nous laisse faire le seul matt sur
la position
hé bé au ring celle-là elle valait la
journée tient petit sou
waouh toujours la forme après trois
heures impressionnant il est fait le
cinquième du classement nous dit anthony
alors je sais pas qui sait il f
waouh alors je pense qu'on n'aura pas le
temps de
on peut essayer peut-être essayer de
faire un nul
pour marquer deux points de plus
voilà c'est une victoire à larache qui
nous fait passer dans les 50 premiers
est-ce qu'on va rester dans les 50
premiers après avec 6 minutes qui
restent à la pendule c'est pas sûr même
probable que non
ce faire passer devant par pas mal de
monde
allez on va jouer avec eux quatre des
six minutes
h4
calais c3
nous c'est 4
au lieu de moins que le 2
on est 5
mais quatre
or venant bien je pense
ce que je vais je vais me redévelopper
part de ce côté
à troyes
des trains
isis
9 4 j'ai trois ans peut-être
la lettre 4
l'autre
car connaissent peut-être 5
il reste quatre minutes 29
pour le tournoi fort et de faire un nul
après bon pour le jeu
aux 3
fo 3 pour empêcher que les d4
le cavalier ici va pouvoir enfin revenir
en jeu par des deux
et si ça leur attention parce que la
belgique après peut-être un peu embêtant
à cause du fond
est-ce que c'est sûr
calais g46 non y apprend reprend sa
marche pas avec le temps après
c'est pas beau aux 3
wave 3 ans mais bon
je fais trois quand même je pense
mais bon c'est pas maintenant que j'y
joue h 4 c'est vrai que j'ai affaiblit
un peu parce que sinon juhasz 3 mai sur
mais une fois qu'on avancé un pion c'est
difficile
le propose nul allez on nous propose nul
pour les points du tournoi
acceptez-le a joué cinq ans pas grâce à
la peut-être déstabilisé
alors on va pas jouer qu'avec des scènes
parce que brio vous prend
quoique
normal car le dos et plus sûr on laisse
le car garé fils pour éviter qu'ils nous
envoient f5 trop tôt
et s'il joue cavalier h5 g4 est le cas
il n'y a pas de case vraiment
bon maintenant peut-être on va jouer
avec des quatre maintenant on va ouvrir
ici et avec ces structures de pionsat à
ça a du sens de commencer à jouer à
lille dame
ça va
pour l'instant
et
donc
peut-être des 4
cavalier d2
ou d'amd 2 bien sûr comme t2 aussi mais
si je fais d'amd 2 g + 2
le plus de gaz pour mon cas libyen
bon il va falloir s'activer un peu les
amis
allez je joue avec g4
c'est gonflé mais bon
faire je vois pas quoi
d'autres
ou l'or
il faut prendre pas trop réfléchi en
fougères
tout peut encore
non
[Musique]
et des deux
il aurait dû jouer fou et 6 il attaque
et hkd maintenant je peux jouer car les
f3
software 6 s'il avait fait le coup
d'avant je pouvais pas défendre 4 ok
c'est pas mal ça parce que il me
contrôler à cazaux 3 c'est bien vu
c'est un bon coup x 6
2 il veut
annuler non
broos fait rien maintenant mais s'il a
gagné du coup
on a une pièce de plus a quand même hein
donc il va falloir qu'ils juste
tous à eux
[Musique]
plus c'est pas facile ici
classique notre roi il
à part ok donc nos pièces sont pas
placés de manière optimale
au placement
dames 7 ème set j'ai envie de faire
tourner trois tours j'ai 3
pas terrible
alors il va
les pièces
pas simple ici c'est pas simple les
câbles et g3 dans le deux sans doute
après
contrôler la classe de 3 voilà
ouais ça c'est pas mal
tam eux deux donc j'arrive à
attention la casse des quatre aussi
maintenant
[Musique]
ouais fois fou
os 4 c'est un bon coup
certainement un très bon coup
ta main d'homme g2
et donc là cavalier ou deux
il vous la montre la belle joue
clairement la montre à ça y est enfin
une petite raku y aller
on fait une petite crocs ou ici
aie aie aie ça y est on a réussi à
rockets
oui on va prendre ici allez voir
à
tour ici
cette seconde
chaud
schumi se passe rien
à
prendre ici
est ce qu'une seconde à l'art
à
[Musique]
vu comme ils sont la joie la formule
tout ça bon allez on a quand même fait
un bon tournoi
allez donc ses victoires du maître fide
tormenta negra qui fait une grosse perf
à 2500
deuxième aux knicks qui fait une perf à
les troisièmes ultra chess qui fait une
performance à 2168 ont fini 52e bah
c'est pas mal parce que l'objectif
c'était dans les cinq premiers on y est
on n'est pas loin des 50 premiers à deux
places donc c'est quand même l'objectif
est bien réussie avec une perf à 2204
bon
même trois parties jouées pas de berserk
position moyenne à 2034 trois heures de
jeu
et
je suis tranquille je vais je vais me
reposer un salut à adrie salua dry
bon mais c'est cool alors si vous voulez
jouer
2 3
2-3 blitz
c'est le moment
un acquis non mais on va je vais
peut-être me tiens je vais peut-être
calais le tournoi de saint denis
samedi après midi
[Musique]
allez
allez team tournament
et standard
trois minutes plus 2 secondes donc le
classement a montré que c'était le
c'était bien ce qui plaisait le plus
deux secondes on va faire ça
pas de père sec
amber au team diagonale tv et on va
faire ça donc ça me dit
il
à 15 heures
ça vous va
face à notre pôle en fait pour savoir
notre sondage
savoir si ça vous plaît vraiment ça je
sais pas
voilà
on est bien le n 2 donc 23 24 ans sera
le 25 à 3 heures de l'après midi
voilà donc un tournoi blitz 2
alors la durée
cent vingt minutes
du récent des minutes donc ces
diagonales tv spirit ce public voilà le
3 + 2 on fait ça samedi à 15 heures pour
ceux que ça intéresse
puis on en fera un autre mardi c'est
bien le mardi le mardi ça marche bien
voilà j'en fais pas trop ce que je peux
pas jouer les tournants tout le temps
c'est pas possible
alors on ne s'écoule ça
15 heures je ferai une fois que je fasse
un sondage dès que j'ai le temps parce
que ça prend de temps à ok
allez on fait ça samedi 15h public en
minutes 2 secondes
durée 2 heures
beurre de la team diagonale tv
ça à 15 heures
c'est parti
voilà donc si vous êtes membre de la
team diagonale tv sur mon lit chess
vous allez trouver le tournoi simplement
vous allez sur la page de bonal tv vous
avez la liste des tournois comme ça et
les membres de l'équipe on est combien
260 pas mal voilà donc voilà vous pouvez
si ça vous intéresse ça me dit vous
pouvez déjà vous inscrire bon je ferai
des annonces ok donc résumé de la
journée du coup
on a fait une perf à 2204 sur 23 parties
avec un taux de victoire à 65%
on a fait des belles parties
c'est quoi la partie intéressante qu'on
a gagné tout à l'heure
partis du jour je dirais c'était pas la
plus belle mais je trouvais que c'était
la plus
[Musique]
combative
c'est pas ça
ça
trouve fois
ça en a perdu ses deux 1740
oui
non c'était perdre
ça il me semble
aussi cela en fait contre il f
deux parties là donc on a joué avec vous
ces six et en fait on était assez mal
voire même très mal je pense qu'on a
pris une bonne décision ici un jour 1 h
4 voilà on a sacrifié ici l'accepter
sacrifices et on a pris d'option pour la
pièce et on est moins bien c'est sûr
même l'a d'ailleurs il aurait ici
l'aurait dû ici aurait dû prendre le
pion aux 5
tout de suite nous a permis de le
défendre
qui fait que en fait j'aurais pas dû
jouer faut aussi semé foot 17 pour
garder le contrôle du pion et après bon
là on n'est toujours pas bien mais bon
si on élimine les pions c'est dur de la
gagne et quand même là h3 est
intéressant et là je crois que j'ai joué
un coup intéressant autour d'eux salaire
très bon d'ailleurs c'est le coût que
propose de leech s non il ya tour de est
aussi tour ces trois j'avais un fichier
à tour ces trois aussi mais je prouvais
tour de plus l'idée c'était que sitôt f2
tour elle menace de gagner le fou
l'objet de revenir et on répète donc on
menace de faire mieux alors qu'en fait
on se bat pour pour ne pas perdre
et là l'idée c'est qu'on essaie d'ouvrir
la diagonale ici de manière à pouvoir me
mettre notre fou pour attaquer l'euro à
là on a fait ça avec l'idée s'il avait
joué tour g8 en disant bestial comme ça
le foot louer mais non parce qu'ils font
échec et aprilia tout reprend échec en
plus qui fait que yann même pas de pion
à la prise prise fou prend là il a pris
le pion m6 et là il n'a pas vu qu'il
faisait contre-attaqué là je me lasse
pas tant de coups avec tous ici et tour
ici
cavalier trois échecs et fous ces cinq
clous lecavalier
la menace de gagner le cavalier ou mais
en fait c'est mana surtout matt
alors en fait ils pouvaient ici sans
doute ouais il peut jouer tour chez sis
tout simplement
et il s'en sort un tas de problèmes
il s'en sort en tout cas il peut
continuer à jouer comme je n'avais plus
beaucoup de temps en fait est là il fait
tout reste rare il se prend en main
[Musique]
c'est une victoire importante parce que
c'est un joueur 2345 et on a marqué
quatre 4 points
bon après il en a fait d'autres où on a
notre partie disons ça des joueurs moins
bon qu'on a perdu aussi mais bon dans
l'ensemble c'est quand même pas trop mal
52e sur 3757 c'est même très bien on va
dire tiens on va regarder où se trouve
ce tournoi parmi le classement de huit
tournois les meilleurs résultats voilà
qu'on a fini combien 52 voilà c'est
celui là il ya 3 heures donc on est 1 2
3 4 5 6 et notre sixième meilleure
performance quand même c'est pas mal
qu'on a créé ce compte ça fait pas
longtemps ça fait depuis décembre trois
quatre mois
on a fait tous ces tourments là
le mieux qu'on ait fait caresser 9e sur
pl le classement apparemment il est sûre
le le ratio en fait la division
placement / nombre de joueurs donc plus
apte joueurs et plus vous êtes au bien
sûr plus et c'était le meilleur le
deuxième on a fini 14e sur 1600 2 mais
bon celui-là était pas trop mal on a
réussi un bon
c'est bien à noter que dans les
meilleures perfs c'était la victoire la
semaine dernière dans le diagonal tv
spirit beat arena c'est vrai c'était
sympa
1,79 mais voyez c'est pas la meilleure
perf parce que c'est mieux de faire 9e
sur 2254 sûr dans les dix premiers ça
c'était un très beau très jolie tourne
il ya trois semaines
là vous pouvez voir vos si donc vous
allez dans le tournoi ray vous regardez
sur la gauche on tournoi ici sur votre
gauche vous avez mes tournois et là vous
avez sur la gauche encore un petit menu
et vous faites meilleurs résultats
voilà et vous avez donc vous voyez quels
sont vos meilleurs résultats en tournoi
c'est sympa qui a les stats aussi
tu fais 32 tournoi apparemment
32 points en moyenne dans les tournois
sont des points 9 128 g en moyenne dans
les 10% dans les 10%
qui joue un peu en rapide noyer met pas
beaucoup je fais
deux tournois bon je fais quelques
parties rapides mais pas j'ai dû en
faire
designer
ok
cool
donc c'est là dessus qu'on va se quitter
merci d'avoir suivi ce live
j'espère que ça vous a plu surtout que
ça vous fait progresser que vous jouer
aux échecs
oubliez pas dans la description de vous
abonner au
différentes autres chaînes des gones ltv
aux réseaux sociaux si vous voulez être
au courant je vous l'annoncé en général
quand je lance ce live
j'essaie de réfléchir à d'autres
formules et puis je vais aussi voir le
si sur le meilleur jour horaires qui
vous intéresse pour jouer c'est pas
évident de savoir
ok
allez ciao ciao bye portez vous bien